[Music]
it is week two of the masked singer and
another mass celeb has gone home we're
gonna get into all of it plus stick
around because the show's lead costume
designer marina toy bina is here yes
that is right I'm so excited she's here
for a small but sadly the pandemonium
was not enough because the Panda went a
packet and take a look
[Applause]
Queen goddess Laila Ali boxing legends
legend
okay did you see this coming I think the
clues led into a bit of athlete we kind
of saw that one there and Robin even
guessed it on the top without a
performance yeah I was really impressed
by that guest by the way because Laila
Ali is someone who is incredibly smart
and strong and athletic and empowering
but she definitely did not cross my mind
so when Robin was like maybe like a
Laila Ali I was like oh okay he's on to
something
start backtracking a little you know I
think it's incredible that this was sort
of like a beautiful love letter or no
maje to her father who she obviously
holds so dearly in her heart um what
gave it away for you or what stumped you
what stumped me I think we got the
athlete clues that made sense did a
little research after and she does have
a cookbook
yeah but she's no stranger to
competition reality shows she was on
Dancing with the Stars in 2006 the new
Celebrity Apprentice in 2017 so she had
to check this one off her list - yes go
Queen Leila you know this woman is
unstoppable she can dance she can sing
she can cook she can do it all and I
can't wait to see what she does next and
she was funny to her performance I loved
all of it she did a great job incredible
so with the Pentagon we're left to keep
guessing who's underneath the remaining
three costumes so let's crawl into the
Black Widow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
work the stage oh my goodness I mean I'm
having a vision hahaha I know where
you're going
that's a raven symone yes I mean so
you're putting your bed on Raven Symone
here that my money everything I got is
on Raven Symone singing their hair
that's her okay let's let's go to some
receipts I also think it's Raven Symone
a couple of things really tipped me off
and gave it away number one in the clue
package we see a picture of a peach so a
peach of course represents Georgia
Atlanta whatever you want to say about
that so I started started off thinking
maybe it's like a real housewife okay
right but then think about it Raven
Symone she has a show or she had a show
called state of Georgia the girl was
born in Georgia
okay so Paige has a big part in this of
her life correct so that's our first big
clue then she references the phrase my
house okay of course we've got the show
Ravens home on Disney Channel there was
a reference to directing so I started
thinking is it a tried and true director
but then we go on IMDB and we see Raven
she actually has worked as if director
that she's kind of gearing into that
phase of her career which is really
exciting
and then also the whole darker and
edgier thing and I always think of a
Disney star because a lot of them start
off so like sugary and bubblegum sweet
and and Raven has really kind of
transitioned nicely into adulthood and
she wants to show us that she's not
always gonna be this like sugary sweet
sort of star she's actually like an
adult who's got visions yes
performance skills and it's not the
first time we heard this clue but living
in the public eye obviously these are
all celebrities who have all lived in
the public eye but I mean Raven Symone I
grew up watching that so Raven and then
she moved on and she was a co-host on
the view for a while so she's really
been in the public eye forever this is
such an awesome step we haven't heard
her sing in a while again we're hoping
it's her I think it's her but yeah this
is cool to hear her again yeah and let's
let's like call a spade a spade the girl
can say oh completely we know she can
sing she was a Cheetah Girl okay and I'm
very excited I guess we'll get into this
later but there could be some very
exciting Cheetah Girls things happening
on this show in front of our very eyes
which is very exciting
I'll be honest I thought it was Naya
Rivera at first I'm definitely leaning
more Rayven
the moment but I did think strongly Naya
Rivera I'll tell you why
Naya loves Halloween and in the original
clue package from the like preview
episode that we got to see there were a
lot of note like nods to full of tricks
and there was Halloween music and even
the spider felt very Halloweeny to me
also this song I want to dance with
somebody was performed on Glee by Naya
Rivera and Heather Morris negate with me
[Music]
it just made sense right did that ever
cross your mind did cross my mind I mean
I love her again I think the tone of the
voice was very recognizable and I
thought oh that sounds a lot like Li nya
bring some research we saw she performed
the song but Raven is just sticking with
me all the way and well we have all of
our guesses here we did go online and
take a look it's anybody's guess with
this show and we pulled a few of our
favorites That's So Raven
obviously there are so many iconic memes
people were really pulling those out and
posting those online but people are also
thinking taraji P Henson again guys it's
not tirage like it's not like I know but
I'm gonna like I'm just gonna put it out
there it's not to rival dr. Ozzie last
week there won't really watch her Ozzy
on this show I love her but I just I
think she's too busy right now and this
one was I just had to laugh at it I mean
if the Black Widow mask isn't Scarlett
Johansson I'm gonna be so angry I mean I
completely cut it I appreciate that the
funny guess there could you imagine I
would I would love to see Scarlett
Johansson on the show again I don't
think she's doing it I think she's a
little bit well we were looking at all
your guesses we also want to take a look
at the next mask perhaps you'll be able
to identify the leopard
[Music]
[Applause]
the second the leopard opened their
voice and we heard the magical toad that
has got to be seal I mean I am such it's
like me nerdy how much of a seal was I I
really like oh my god kiss from a rose
it's like the soundtrack to my childhood
like riding in the car with my parents
growing up I just I love seals so much
so listen clue package the leopard goes
I know what it's like to be on top while
I went and I looked it up seal has one
number one hit and three top-ten hits so
the guy is full of hits the course the
the package made me sad because the
leopard went from talking about how
great they were at XY and z to then sort
of being like people just care about the
celebrity culture and it made me feel
like oh this is someone who's been
ridiculed by like tabloid culture or
scandal and I googled and Steele has
said this he said it's nice to be in
newspapers and magazines for something
other than my marriage he obviously had
a very famous relationship with Heidi
Klum for many years and I think that he
wrote her sorry he said quote headlines
have come to define me and I don't think
that of seal but it breaks my heart if
that's how he feels headlines were
actually a huge part of that clue
package though we saw three news paper
strategically placed throughout the clue
packet it's writing a flat on a table
being held up and they said crazy game
ends with a win for the leopard out of
hits and out of time and the run away so
these are obviously nodding to tabloid
headlines we have seen surrounding seal
right and then on a very basic level we
know seal is British so of course we've
got like a very Elizabethan outfit on
the on the leopard it's very baroque it
just kind of feels very reminiscent of
like English culture and then the second
that got the guy like I know the second
the leopard opened their voice and just
started singing seal is one of the most
recognizable voices in music do you have
any other guesses I thought that one of
the interesting guesses was robbing he
said Billy Porter Billy Porter is huge
right now I mean he's been on Broadway
for years yeah the guy can sing but word
season recently and I think that it's
interesting because he pointed out that
Billy holds his mic with two hands just
like this master
so there were a lot of body language
also pointing body language towards
Billy Porter but I am with you on this
one I'm really pointing towards steel
and the height of him I mean they made
comments the entire time like that is a
tall leopard seal is six foot four yes
totally
what are they saying online online for
this one um steel has a song called
loves divine it's seal seal as the
leopard end of story
I think you wrote that one wasn't me but
I think one two people actually said the
leopard is RuPaul a hundred percent
changed my mind not seal hmm I'm not
falling for that one actually RuPaul was
filming drag race at the same time that
the masked singer was filming this
summer so I'm not going with RuPaul
anymore my production style production
schedules for you guys so it's basically
impossible it's impossible for that to
be RuPaul and lastly let's shake our
tail feathers and check out the Flamingo
[Music]
I am the biggest Adrienne Bailon
houghton fan this has got to be Adrienne
she was strutting around that stage like
she was back in Barcelona it was a
girl's mo man it was and if it really is
Raven in the Black Widow costume and it
really is Adrienne in the Flamingo
costume we would truly be getting the
unofficial Cheetah Girls reunion we've
always wanted we've always wanted so
I've got a lot of receipts on this one
since I'm such a huge adrienne fan so
very very basic she mentioned a zu Tube
channel we know Adrienne has got her
channel it's called all things Adrienne
she talks about everything from hair and
makeup and relationships so that's very
much on brand
she mentioned things like the real story
there was also a picture of a cross we
know Adrienne does a jewelry line which
is actually very faith focused and she
said later in the episode that the
Flamingo is a symbol of luxury so I am
your escape and if you follow Adrienne
you know she loves traveling she got
married in Paris she's a woman of the
world
she travels everywhere everywhere what
were you thinking so she actually
addressed this on the real last week
obviously also on Fox they brought it up
right away Twitter blew up after the
preview performance we saw two weeks ago
and immediately started tweeting
Instagram commenting everything towards
her take a look at what she had to say I
literally don't understand how people
can think I can do this show at 4
o'clock in the morning and that show at
night let's start there let's start
there okay I'm gonna pull a CBS link
mercy on this one she's claiming
obviously that she can do both shows at
once well luckily for her the reel was
actually on hiatus from May 15th until
September 16th
so she was if she had a nice little
vacation where she made her way over to
the masked singer because they were
filming from July 1st to August 9th
according to one of the ticketing
websites Wow you did some I did some
deep hearted eyes and one of her
co-hosts is also agreeing with us there
they are all agree
since she also had to say this as well
no it was a run that the Flamingo did
hmm and I heard a little bit of your
voice oh yeah and it was like the Chat
Chat know do you got me
I mean it's Tamara I'm with you girl
where Adrian has one of the most
recognizable voices I grew up in the 3lw
era so that's where I first like really
became a huge fan of hers and then
obviously through the Cheetah Girls era
and now she's in this beautiful phase of
life where she's you know enjoying being
a wife and a talk-show host but I think
when you're a true performer that
passion never really dies and the mass
singer is such an incredible platform a
place for her to be like listen I've got
these vocal chops like I told her I
interviewed her not that long ago and I
was like please put out some new music
cuz we love you and we love dancing to
your music and of course I asked her
about would you ever do a Cheetah Girls
reunion but take a look at what she said
Raven and I have kept a great
relationship and I love Raven to them I
mean it's literally true chiumbo Bowles
for life in real life and we've actually
gone and like hung out in Vegas and have
had good times like that and we've had
conversations about like just how crazy
that would be if ever we did do a fourth
or just like that another cheetalicious
project so of course everybody is
buzzing and a lot of people are onto
what you and I have been saying about
Adrienne this is what smidge shady said
even the mannerisms say Adrienne by lon
you busted sis and then Amanda khopesh
said my little middle schooler heart is
so happy to hear Raven Symone and
Adrienne by lon on the mass as well
Amanda all three of us we're in
agreement
so we could sit here all day and
speculate about who's under this mask
who's under that mask we're all about
receipts we go straight to the source
so we have brought in the lead costume
designer on the masked singer it's
marina toy bina thank you so much for
joining us No thank you for having me
I'm so excited let's just start at the
beginning on a very like kind of basic
level this this new season starts
there's a whole new crop of celebrities
that are brought in what is your first
thing that you do and I mean just like
every season we do the artwork I
collaborate with one of my great artists
and I do all the artwork by a hand and
then we digitally kind of enhance the
artwork make it 2d and then from there
the sketches are then proposed to the
network and we try to see what makes it
different from season one and kind of
choose our favorites and then it's being
proposed while the casting is going on
to the talent that's being booked in the
shop
so once the talent is solidified then
you know you've got this amazing crop of
celebrities that are about to come in
and do the show how closely do you work
with them are they allowed to say listen
marina I've got this vision I want to be
the ladybug I want to be the leopard or
is it more you kind of steering the ship
and being like listen I have an idea for
you um it works both ways it's a it's a
full collaboration to where if I know
who it is you know and about three or
four designs are being pitched pert
talent to see so they have variations
they have ideas and then when I get to
meet with them I kind of see what's
going on where who are they about who do
they want to represent why do certain
costumes mean something to them and then
from there it does become collaboration
where I do get notes or you know they're
very happy with the artwork that we see
and then we do kind of try to replicate
the costumes to tease so there's no
surprises you talked a lot about
ventilation and overheating in those
costumes how are they staying cool in
there I mean those are huge costumes
they're singing and performing and
dancing and on that stage we have a lot
of great talent that actually makes it
work but then from a technical
standpoint would you test out the masks
before anybody wears them and as we're
building them I'll try them on or the
fabricators will try them on we make
sure everything has enough oxygen flow
as well as being able to visually see
and also like project the voices out
without any echo and then when the
costumes hit a certain shape or a
certain height we do have enough for him
to put fans in which is what we've done
for season one and that was one of the
ways the monster stayed cool so there's
literally a fan inside this helmet in
the shade spatula base of the costume we
we were able to put some fans internally
and then also ventilate the actual mask
portion of the costume well if you have
the time we'd love to play a little word
association with you we're just gonna
name some costumes tell us the first
thing that comes to mind it could be
anything about the costume the person
maybe some secrets whatever you got all
right Panda
oversized leopard over embroidered
flamingo Nestle black widow pink crowd
with shiny
butterfly yeah chuckle here you go fly
away flower majestic fox super here
ladybug penguin tail coat Rottweiler
gold chain skeleton Tim Burton
thingamajig I have no idea
and last one tree Christmas marina thank
you so much for coming in and spilling
everything that you were allowed to say
thank you guys thank you so much for
having me here
no really excited we love having you and
we love the show and so with three
contestants gone and four new masks to
meet next week there's still plenty of
guessing to be done and of course we
want to know what you are all thinking
as well so leave us a comment with your
best and craziest theories tweet us so
we can all guess together I'm at Charles
E O'Keefe and I'm at Deidre Behar we'll
see you next week
[Music]
you